ترحيب أجنبي في البرنامج ،
هل يمكنني أن أشكرك كيرستن على استضافتي ،
هل يمكنني أن أبدأ بمطالبتك بالرد على
ذلك الطالب الشاب الذي قال إننا
لسنا الجيل السابق ولن
نعيدك أنت الجيل السابق الذي
شاهدته بالفعل احتجاجك على
الأرض في إيران ورأيناهم
يسحقهم النظام ، هل تعتقد أن الأمر سيكون
مختلفًا هذه المرة
نعم بالتأكيد أعتقد أن هذه نقطة تحول
وأه بالتحديد هذا هو السبب
لأننا نرى تغييرًا في الأجيال
وتحولًا جوهريًا في الأعراف و
قيم هذا الجيل من هذا الجيل الذي
ولدت في الثمانينيات وأولئك الذين
احتجوا منا في عام 2009 لا يزال لدينا أمل في
الإصلاح الانتخابي وفي الإصلاح الهيكلي
في الجمهورية الإسلامية ، يتم كتابة
شعارنا كان واضحًا جدًا
مرت ريامارو أو أعاد تصويتي  لكن
ما نراه اليوم هو
أم تعلم أننا نرى أن
حق المرأة والمرأة يحتل مركز
الصدارة في هذه الاحتجاجات وأن
معظم المتظاهرين في الشوارع في الواقع
ينتمون إلى  الجيل الذي ولد
في عام 2000 وما بعده والكثير من متظاهري الفريق
الذين تم إطلاق النار عليهم في الشوارع خلال الأسابيع الثلاثة الماضية
يبلغون من العمر 16 عامًا و 17 عامًا وأعتقد أن هذا
تغيير واضح جدًا وواضح في
السياسة
المستقبلية للمجتمع الإيراني بالإضافة إلى
التحول الجيلي في
المعايير والقيم الأساسية حسنًا ، لذا دعني أسألك
عن أهمية ما حدث
في جامعة شريف ، إنها جامعة النخبة جدًا ،
والعديد من الإيرانيين الذين يمرون
بما تعرفه يذهبون إلى  اذهب لجامعة هارفارد إلى كل
أنواعكم تعرفون أهمية أه
الأكاديميات ذات المستوى العالي أه الأكاديميات في جميع أنحاء
العالم ولكن أيضًا حقيقة أنه
كان هناك قمع هناك ، لذا
فإن أهمية هذا الموقع إلى
جانب حقيقة أن الانسجام
جاء مما اعتقده بعض الناس
هل كنت تعرف فراش موته لتدين وتفعل
ذلك في أكاديمية الشرطة العسكرية ، ما
هو المغزى من هاتين المسألتين
؟  امتلاكها في
حرم جامعة الشريف للتكنولوجيا
هو علامة مهمة للغاية ومثيرة للقلق
على أن الحكومة الحالية التي
تعرفها تاريخيًا من الواضح أن
لديهم تاريخًا في اتخاذ إجراءات صارمة ضد
حرم الجامعة ، ما أعتقد أن جامعة شريف على
وجه الخصوص مهمة
لأنها تعرف أحدها
أعرق الجامعات في الدولة
وممثلها كما ذكرت
في العالم هي
مؤسسة أكاديمية مهمة للغاية وما رأيناه
ردًا على هذه
الحملة العنيفة على الطلاب
والأساتذة الذين أصيبوا برصاص مطاطي
واعتقلوا
بعد ذلك  الأكاديمية الدولية
تستجيب في الواقع بسرعة
وبشدة وتدين هذه
الحملة القمعية على الكون في
حرم جامعة الشريف ، ومن ناحية أخرى
أعتقد أن حقيقة أن Harmony اختار
أكاديمية الشرطة
أم تعلمون لخطابه بعد
ثلاثة أسابيع.  الصمت هو
لفتة قوية للغاية ضد الأكاديميين
وضد s  حركة طالبة كانت أحد
المحركات الرئيسية للتغيير
والاحتجاجات الاجتماعية في الماضي
لعقود في إيران ما رأيته أمس
في وئام كان الخطاب دعوة
للقوات المسلحة
لقمع المتظاهرين بوحشية وخاصة على
الحركة الطلابية ولكني أرى أيضًا
أنه يخلق ثنائية واضحة جدًا
وخطيرة جدًا بين الأكاديميين
والباحثين المستقلين والعلماء
والطلاب والقوات المسلحة والشرطة
ويعزز بشكل أساسي
وحشية الشرطة ضد المتظاهرين